what I want to do in this video is
review all of the neat and bizarre
things that we've learned about
triangles so first we learn so let me
just draw a bunch of triangles for
ourselves so let's have a triangle right
over there the first thing that we
talked about is a perpendicular
bisectors of the sides of the triangles
so if we take so let's take let's bisect
at this side right over here and let's
draw a perpendicular line to it so this
line right over here would be the
perpendicular bisector of this side
right over here
so it's bisecting and it is
perpendicular let's draw another
perpendicular bisector right over here
so we're going that this is the midpoint
of that side let's draw perpendicular so
this is perpendicular and this length is
equal to this length and then let's do
one over let's do one over here this
looks like the midpoint of that side
right over there and then we will draw a
perpendicular it's perpendicular and we
know that this length is equal to this
length right over here and what we
learned is the the where all of these
perpendicular bisectors intersect and
what's neat about this and frankly all
the things we're going to talk about in
this video is that they do intersect in
one unique point that one unique point
is equidistant from the vertices of this
triangle so this distance is going to be
equal to this distance which is going to
be equal to that distance and because
it's equally equidistant to the vertices
you could draw a circle of that radius
that goes through the vertices so you
could draw a circle of that radius that
goes through goes through the vertices
and that's why we call this right over
here that point that intersection of the
perpendicular bisectors so let me write
this down just we can keep track of
things perpendicular perpendicular
bisectors perpendicular bisectors we
call this point right over here our
circumcenter circumcenter because it is
the center of our circumcircle
a circle that that it can be
circumscribed about this triangle so
this is our circumcircle sir
Circle and the radius of the
circumcircle the distance between the
circumcenter and the vertices is the
circum or radius so that was a
perpendicular bisectors now the next
thing we learned and the whole point of
this video is just to make sure that we
can differentiate between these things
and not get too confused so let me draw
another arbitrary triangle right over
here the next thing we thought about is
well what about if we were to bisect the
angles so not we're not talking about
perpendicular bisector the sides but
we're not talking about bisecting the
angles themselves so we could bisect to
this angle right over here so let me
draw my best attempt to draw it and so
this angle is going to be equal to that
angle we could bisect this angle right
over here we could bisect on that's I
could do a better version than that so
that looks well one more try so I could
bisect it like that and then if I'm
bisecting it this angle is going to be
equal to that angle and then if I bisect
this one we know that this angle is
going to be equal to that angle over
there and once again we have proven to
ourselves that they all intersect in a
unique point and this point instead of
being equidistant from the vertices this
point is equidistant from the sides of
the triangle so if you're dropping
perpendicular to each of the sides so
this distance is going to be equal to
that distance which is going to be equal
to that distance and because of that we
can draw a circle that is tangent to the
size that has this radius we could draw
a circle we could draw a circle that
looks like this and we call this circle
because it's kind of inside the triangle
we call it an in circle in circle and
this point we can call which is the
intersection of these of these angle
bisectors we can call this we can call
this the in radius now the other thing
we learned about angle bisectors and
this was we just had to draw one so let
me just draw another triangle right over
here and let me draw an angle bisector
so I'm gonna bisect this angle so this
angle is equal to that angle
and let me label some points here so
let's say that this is changes of colors
let's say that is a this is B this is C
and this is D we learned that if AC is
really the angle bisector of angle B ad
that the ratio between that a b over b c
over b c is going to be equal to the
ratio of ad to d c ad to d c sometimes
this is called the angle bisector
theorem so that's that's neat so the
next thing we learned is let's draw
another triangle here this is just to be
an overview of everything we've been
covering in the last few videos so let
me draw another triangle here so now
instead of drawing the perpendicular
bisector so let me label everything this
was angle bisectors this is angle
bisectors and now what I'm going to
think about are the medians the medians
so the perpendicular bisectors were from
the midpoint or Peart lines that bisect
the sides and they are perpendicular but
don't necessarily go through the
vertices when we talk about medians we
are talking about we are talking about
points that bisect the sides but they go
to the vertices and but they're not
necessarily perpendicular so let's draw
some medians here so let's say this is
the midpoint of that side right over
there so we could draw a median like
that notice it's going through the
vertices these did not necessarily go
through the vertices vertices this right
over here is not necessarily
perpendicular but we do know that this
length is equal to that length right
over there let me draw a couple of more
medians right over here so this the
midpoint looks like it's right about
here the midpoint looks like it's right
about there so this length is equal to
that length and those that goes through
the vertex but it's not necessarily
perpendicular and then this one see the
midpoint looks like it's right about
well right about there and once again
all of these are concurrent they all
intersect at one point right over here
and so this length right over here is
equal to this length right over here
there was a bunch of neat things about
medians when you draw the three medians
will write like this that unique
point where they intersect we called it
the centroid centroid and as I mentioned
and you might learn this later on in
physics is if this was a uniform
triangle if it had a uniform density and
if you were to throw it or rotate it in
the air it would rotate around its
centroid which is essentially it would
essentially be its center of mass it
would rotate around that as its flying
through the air if it had some type of
rotational or I guess you could say
angular momentum but the neat thing
about this is also divides this triangle
to six triangles of equal area so this
this triangle has the same trying areas
that triangle we proved this in several
videos ago
each of these six triangles all have all
have the same area the other thing that
we learned about medians is that the
where the centroid sits on each of the
medians is two-thirds along the median
so the ratio of this side of this length
to this length is two to one or this is
two-thirds along the way of the median
this is two-thirds of the median this is
one-third of the median so the ratio is
two to one another related thing we
learned this wasn't really that
necessarily about medians but it's a
related concept it was the idea of a
medial triangle a medial triangle like
this where you take the midpoint of each
side the midpoint of each side and you
draw a triangle that connects the
midpoints of each side we call this
triangle a medial triangle medial
triangle and we proved to ourselves that
this when you draw a medial triangle it
separates this triangle into four four
triangles that not only have equal area
but the four triangles here are actually
they are actually congruent triangles
and not only are they congruent but
we've shown that this side is parallel
to this side that let me do it use some
more colors here this side is parallel
actually I shouldn't draw two arrows
like that that side is parallel to that
side this side is parallel to this side
and then you have this side is parallel
to this side right here and this length
is half of that length this length is
half of that length this length is half
of that length and it really just comes
out of the fact that these are all these
are for couldn't grew into triangles
and then the last thing that we touched
on is drawing altitudes of a triangle
so there's medians medial triangles and
I'll draw one last triangle over here
and here I'm gonna go from each of the
vertex and I'm not gonna go to the
midpoint of the other side I'm gonna
drop up perpendicular to the other side
so here I will drop a perpendicular but
this isn't necessarily bisecting the
other side once again going to drop a
perpendicular but not necessarily
bisecting the other side and then drop a
perpendicular but not necessarily
bisecting the other side and we've also
proven to ourselves so these are the
altitudes of the triangle altitudes of
the triangle and these also intersect in
a unique is also intersect in a unique
point and I want to be clear this unique
point does not necessarily have to be
inside of the triangle then the same
thing was true of the perpendicular
bisectors it actually could be outside
of the triangle and this unique point we
call an ortho orthocenter
so I'll leave you there and hopefully
this was useful because I know it can
get confusing you know wait how is the
median different than a circumcenter
which is different than an ortho center
or an enraged nor any of these type of
things so hopefully this clarified
things a little bit